[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to wisdom for life
where we shift through philosophy to
find practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life
hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by my
co-host dr. Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about a very difficult problem
for a lot of people which is balancing
autonomy with connection so this is
something we've been talking about back
and forth for quite a while as a theme
and we thought it would make a good show
topic so why is this such a big problem
it's I don't know the the human
condition of like learning how to be in
a relationship and not be in total
control of everything you have that and
a lot of times we overshoot thinking
that that is going to be the best way to
go about things what do you think well I
think we've got like two compatible but
often competing goods at play here we'll
talk about what autonomy isn't just a
bit but let's just throw the word out
there and say it's a good thing right so
being an autonomous developing as a
person getting to make your own choices
we usually look at that as something
good and then we also value connection
with other people and you know what
we're talking about here could apply
particularly to romantic relationships
but it could just as well apply to
friendships or other kinds of
partnership or even you know work
colleagues fellow students roommates you
know there's this this need that we have
as human beings at least some of the
time for being involved with being
intimate with being connected with other
people so you know it would sound like
okay well that's not a problem right
you're just two autonomous people or you
know maybe multiples of them within some
sort of you know matrix of connection
but I think for a lot of people this
winds up being quite quite difficult
and and sometimes quite scary and you
could have two people who really tense
ease with this as well and and you know
so you know this show was about
philosophy we're gonna talk about some
philosophical concepts that can help
with this but it just very broadly
speaking I think that a lot of people
you know when it comes to relationships
they it's sort of like you know doing
doing other preparatory work you know
the best time to have done something for
a crisis was like six months ago and to
start training for it right and then the
second best time is now when you're in
the middle of it and I think with
relationships it works the same way
people just sort of assume that they're
gonna work out they're going to they're
gonna flow along normally and and so if
they don't put in the time to understand
what's going on and to maybe make some
choices to do things a bit differently
then then when the proverbial
you-know-what hits the fan they wind up
in all sorts of problems and you know
there's nations on both sides yeah go
ahead and I want to make sure that we're
we're conveying that we're talking in
all sorts of relationships not just
romantic but also friendships through
your work boss relationships and like
roommates anything that you know puts
you in association with others that you
know a lot of times that you have to
rely upon or that you have some
long-standing engagements that we were
there and another thing is kind of this
is building on I think one of the
reasons we talked about this was our
episode on building good boundaries and
how it is dependent upon a lot of times
the type of the relationship that we are
actually speaking about in this moment
yeah and you know the boundaries thing
is interesting because you think about
friendships for example there are people
who in a friendship don't observe a
certain kind of let's call it reserve
with their friend and they think that if
you're friends with somebody well that
means you share everything together and
you know you can say and do anything you
like in front of the person
and the other person might not be so
cool with that but you know then maybe
they don't say anything about it the
first time that it happens and the other
person gets the wrong idea and you know
it would be great to have set the
boundary at the beginning like I was
saying right but often times were we're
having to do this almost retrospectively
we say you know I didn't like when you
did this thing and then I mean this is
this is a little bit of a digression
here but this is a very very common
dynamic in relationships when there's a
potential for a fight to take place
person a says I didn't I don't like when
you did this thing that you did five
minutes ago and person B says oh well I
you know it was for this reason and all
that and then person a says see you're
not really listening to what I'm saying
and you're not you know you're not
dealing with this this is this is
something that you've done many times
then person B will say oh no no no we're
just talking about right now and person
a is like well I don't want to just talk
about right now I want to talk about
this thing that keeps on happening and
now you now you've got you know the
potential for a great big fight people
are you know they're taking opposite
sides and they're not just you know like
in a back-and-forth thing like in the
cartoons where Bugs Bunny says you know
no an Oliver flood says yes and they go
back and forth until Bugs Bunny pulls
the switcheroo out him and says yes
instead of no it's it's at a meta level
where they're not only arguing about
something substantive they're also
arguing about well what are we actually
doing right here right and and so that
you know that ties in directly with some
of the things we're going to talk about
because when that happens it's as if
both partners are trying to control the
story you know it's it's it's a struggle
on a higher level and it's often you
know quite a problem this hat and like
you say it happens at friendships it can
happen when you're dealing with your
boss or if you're you know coaching an
employee or something like that it
certainly I'll tell you it certainly
happens between teachers and students
well there's a kind of like a built-in
kind are you thinking that someone's
talk
you know almost a hypocritical way and
that's like oh you well you let me do
this thing all this time and now we
bring it up now why was it good why
didn't you bring it up the beforehand
and and I think that's a kind of a
fallacious way of going about that it
took you until this point or like one
realize it is thing that you find to be
proud yeah and we have the autonomy
let's go back to our topic here to make
decisions and change our minds yeah so
let's take that as an opportunity to
jump in and clarify some terms that
people might not be completely familiar
with we're using this word autonomy and
and deep down I think everybody has the
same basic set of ideas about this it's
kind of like a constellation of a couple
different ideas but they might not be
using that that term like when we talk
about not wanting to be bossed around
that's one aspect of being an autonomous
or getting to decide for oneself I think
a lot of people talk about things that
way right you know my rights my freedom
my my capacity to choose so literally
the term means self ruling Nomos is is
law in in Greek and Altos is self so
it's and it's not just getting to do
whatever the hell you want all right
some people think of autonomy that way I
I just get to do anything I want to do
and that I'm autonomous but it's really
about being able to give yourself the
rules that you're going to follow and
and you know maybe other people can can
mesh in with those rules because their
rules are you know compatible with with
yours or even the same or maybe they're
not but if you know if our rules you
know like think about what we're doing
right now there's there's certain sort
of unwritten expectations governing this
this activity of having a conversation
you know at a certain point I should
shut up
and you should start talking right if I
just keep talking and talking and
talking it's not much of a conversations
certainly not a dialogue
and if you like if you really want like
if I can see that you really want to say
something I shouldn't just like keep
blathering on I should actually like
take a pause like this and speak and
then we have a conversation of back and
forth and we go forward and back and
another portion of autonomy or to be
autonomous is one making your own
decisions but also that willingness and
that ability to change your mind given
different circumstances that once you
make an a decision doesn't mean that you
are stuck with that one decision forever
going forward yeah you know that reminds
me of this passage and Epictetus a great
stoic philosopher he ran into a guy who
had decided that he was I think he was
gonna starve himself and epictetus said
you know well what's going on here and
the guy said I have like decided on
something I'm sticking to it I'm gonna
persevere and epictetus said you know it
really has to be something reasonable
for it to be perseverance otherwise it's
just obstinacy it's like picking
something to do and you stick with it
almost look you know like slavishly or
against the rest of the world but you
pick the wrong thing so so you know
being able to figure you know autonomy
doesn't just mean being able to like
decide anything whatever for yourself it
means being able to decide what's good
for you and what is bad for you exactly
yeah that you can reject it yeah yeah
and that changes as we as we get older I
mean I think about stupid stuff that I
did at like almost every stage in my
life including well into my forties and
you know looking back on it I can say
man that was that was not a good
decision what was going on there oh I
understand
here's the decision-making process let's
not do that again because that was that
was actually you know you you behaved
autonomously in a sense but you
certainly didn't get yourself any closer
to what's good for you and sometimes you
entangled yourself and what's bad
so there's a lot of aspects to autonomy
now why is it so difficult to be
autonomous in a relationship I mean
isn't it
aren't relationships these easy things
to manage where we both approach as
individuals and you know we can't work
out a social contract rationally between
ourselves no oh you know it's it's like
oil and water but like wanting so badly
to mix you know we're you know
fundamentally social creatures but it is
also so difficult for us to sit there
and be like happy with all the other
decisions that the people around us make
and especially the closer we are the
closer that we feel like those decisions
that they make affect us you know you
look at your father and there you know
teenage child and they do something that
they considered to be you know uncool
and they cringe as if they are being
destroyed and that their entire lives
are falling down because like you know
their dad made a pun or something out in
public that's you know the closer that
we are the closer we feel the
connections and those on the O's effects
and reputation bring in yeah even if you
don't even know anybody in that crowd
and the you know being in public you can
have that being embarrassed of your
parents thing as a not just a teenager
but also like a preteen as well I think
I'm going by my kids recent experiences
actually I've been pretty fortunate I
haven't had too many play you know times
when my kids are like oh my god this is
terrible what you're doing you know
you're you're you know humiliating me in
public but there's been a few cases and
I remember as a kid you know going
through that myself do you remember that
with your with your parents right yeah
to a certain extent I was I was pretty
your reasonable camera
yeah the autumn is reasonable but in
that regard I was yeah and we could have
similar things too with like our friends
you know our friends can embarrass us or
we can embarrass them or our work
colleagues especially when we take them
to other contexts you know think about
the holiday parties those can go be a
landmine in a way yeah
saying that like I contain multitudes
absolutely correct especially it's very
much context dependent and yeah how I
react and interact with you because this
is a radio show and we had to keep
certain topics in certain words off
exactly I yeah the radio or the airwaves
on that you know this is not a
representation of me that you might get
in a certain other context like if we
were sitting around at the bar and you
know yeah having a few drinks and
shooting the breeze we're not gonna use
the word that we'd normally use for that
yeah I mean those are all interesting
example so autonomy is something that
can often be difficult I'm gonna throw
an idea out there and I don't I'm not
saying that this is actually correct I'm
just gonna say a philosopher presented
things this way and the person I have in
mind is John Paul Sartre he in in Being
and Nothingness and and in other things
as well I mean no exit
you know hell is other people hell is
other people because of this and it's
only it's only hell for for certain
kinds of people he talks about you know
you experience the world that you're in
as a subject as things that you not only
can act upon but you can give value and
meaning to so he you know he talks about
being in a yard or garden or I forget
exactly what it is but there I know
there's like freshly mowed grass there
and he talks about how you know you kind
of constitute this world around you and
you give it the meaning that it has I
mean if you were from a place that
didn't have lawns or anything
know what to make of that mowed grass
and we've seen enough about we've seen
enough of that to just be able to ignore
it and say yes that's that's what it is
and then he talks about another person
straying into that area and this is
typical Sartre
he talks about like all the meaning and
freedom bleeding out of the environment
into this like hole that the other
person creates they're they their
freedom to be able to like redefine the
environment that they're in
means that you're in a way losing your
freedom your freedom is no longer as
operative you can't like determine the
whole of the world around you and think
about like now kids playing with action
figures and then one of them decides the
game is going to be a little bit
different and and the others are all
upset you know how can you do this and
you know adults do this as well in
defining what what sort of situation
they're in or what the relationship is
like I think that that's one of the
dangers the fact that we are autonomous
individuals means that unless we can
figure out how to adequately work live
play love together we get drawn into
these conflicts where it feels like the
other person is dominating us or trying
to or trying to control us or trying to
decide how things are going and they may
not even be doing that we may be it may
be totally projection on our part but if
you've got somebody like us art you know
if that's that's your friend they're
gonna be perpetually thinking you're
doing that even if you're playing doing
innocuous things like playing a game
with them or you know pouring drinks
that you're gonna share in just a minute
you know they can they can call that
into question and so autonomy isn't so
easy to manage as we'd like to think
that there it is a problem for a quite a
few people so in I love that you brought
up Sartre and specifically no exit and
this is that grand like push-pull on yes
the whole play is about
several people who are in hell and it's
not like fire and brimstone
it's just them in a room together and
the whole idea is these characters are
what is making it hellish for those
characters in the room and in the end
the door is open for one of the
characters and they have the opportunity
to leave and they choose not to because
there's that such strong pull for us to
be in some sort of relationship even one
that you hate that you will not remove
yourself potentially yeah and that I
mean that play is great
in part because each of the character
has their there what's wrong with them
they're their flaws right they're there
they're screwed up in this and they they
try to like Inez's the one who says that
she's really mean and you know cruel to
people and she you know she arguably is
in it but she still wants some sort of
redemption
they all do they all want to be they all
want their there whatever is kind of
garbage in their their life and
personality to be turned into something
better and and the way that you know
like as agar saw is is the Garson the
the main guy he proposed while for me
yeah he proposes like they're gonna help
each other out you know and it's not a
innocent like or spontaneous helping
each other out it's like this is how
we're gonna like live together and this
and they can't even do that and you know
hell is other people
when the other people are the kind of
people in that play it doesn't have to
be like that alright this is that but
but if what if you what if you have
somebody that you're involved with who's
like those people in that play or what
if it turns out that you're the one
who's like that right that's where we
that's where we run into some serious
problems and and sometimes we're gonna
be absolutely blind to that
yeah well there is I mean they have that
that's saying right if if everybody that
you've dated or everybody that you're
encountering is a jerk and it's usually
another word that's being used there
maybe it's not actually that it's you
right is how it goes
so you you could have that occur to you
after awhile I suppose but a lot of
people develop almost like a callus of
the soul that allows them not to see
that right to keep displacing it on to
other people but let's I mean this is
this is all good stuff we're talking
about the the problematic situation and
you were corrected as Joseph Garcon oh
good my memory and Anna's in Estelle OS
tell ya yeah the sort of high society
woman exactly there is finder who
climbed her way up yeah yeah so let's
talk about another maybe codependency
yeah I'm it's problematic some some I
mean that's one main obstacle to
autonomy and I think that that's one
that like goes to the root of it you
know when people are codependent they
are relying on on each other and on the
relationship that they're in including
with it's sort of narrative of what the
relationship is like for what autonomy
ought to be delivering to them you might
say so a lot of people will remain stuck
in relationships that are that are not
productive and they keep doing the same
cycle over and over again and you look
at them and you're like wow you really
want to be miserable together don't you
and they can be more or less so right
but there's usually no real opportunity
for growth and and so you can ask well
what's going on there why why are people
like this what creates codependency and
you know if you think about it in terms
of causes it could be like
could be having learned the law wrong
lessons early on in life and and could
be like a fear to try something new but
if you look at it in terms of the
dynamic you have to ask well what are
people getting out of being stuck like
that I don't know if you've ever been
stuck like that I know I have it at
times at times there's I guess I feel
like a broken record to a certain extent
but there's that that want or that need
especially in a romantic relationship to
be in a romantic relationship oh yeah
you know you you both have you're a
hormonal and um
motivations pushing you towards this but
also there's a strong societal push like
oh you should be on in relationship you
should have be married and I have kids
you know depending on it's time to
settle down right and so there's that
yes fear and anxiety of either not or
like being unloved or you know being
alone forever that could also be another
like thing yeah you know this is kind of
a side note here and we'll come back to
the main topic in a minute but you know
I I so you know having lived in this
area and the Midwest I always kind of
took it as well you can always find
somebody you know it's it's not
impossible but you see people talking
about places like New York or London or
Paris or LA and they say that it's so
difficult to like meet somebody and I
think part of it has to do with the
paradox of choice right but the idea
that well you get so many different
people to choose from
who would you possibly commit to and
then all the rest of the people can have
that as well but it but it also seems to
be like the standards are so high that
almost nobody can meet them and they're
all like chasing after these these crazy
things and you you hear and read about
all these people who are very miserable
being alone
and then have you know like a string of
unsatisfactory relationships with you
know occasional glimmers of things being
possibly great and yeah I mean that's
just a side note I think a lot of that
depends on where where you are I mean if
you if you lived way out in the sticks -
and there's very few people who you
could potentially get involved with you
you're kind of stuck with that talent
pool right right I like this idea of I'm
you know one having that that massive
choice but there's also this potential
conflict between different relationships
here yeah and if you're in a London New
York and LA Chicago there is a culture
of like very on being very Oh what is
this your job your work your a career is
that your main focus and so this is
another relationship you versus and your
work your employer your you know your
career goals as a relationship versus
your relationship with you know your
romantic partner and there's a
disconnect there yeah that's that's
quite true and and I think that can
arise for I'm just gonna say you know a
lot of other professional people but it
doesn't even necessarily need to be like
recognized professions anybody can
become a workaholic and going back to
like you know thinking about
codependency and what what traps people
what gets them stuck in these these
positions you know some philosophers
would say that it is a fear of autonomy
a fear of as we're getting we're talking
sort of existentialism here it was since
we started with Sartre this this view
that if I'm actually in charge of myself
and deciding for myself I can't blame
things going bad or not working on
anybody else and it feels like you know
the bar gets raised so if I if I decide
I'm going
be a writer and then I you know what you
know in in in instead of actually
writing I do and I'm gonna use scare
quotes here research all the time you
know going down rabbit holes on the
internet and reading lots of other
people's stuff and you know taking my
laptop to the cafe and then you know
writing like a paragraph and saying okay
I'm done for the day if I never do
anything as a writer well that's my own
damn fault
and I'm in trouble because of that right
so and not in trouble you know in any
legal sense but in in with myself I
can't I can't blame it on circumstances
I can't say that something you're
creating certain expectations for
yourself in which you do not lead up
your actions and actually you know
follow-through and then you feel a sense
of I don't know dread or you know dismay
at your own actions yeah so in
co-dependent relationships when the two
people have been in it for a while they
hold each other back and that proved you
know it that provides a kind of almost
like ballast that that stabilizes things
but it feels bad and then you can say oh
if it wasn't for so-and-so I'd actually
be like taking dance lessons and you
know learning to be graceful or I don't
know writing a novel or you know
becoming going to school and doing these
things or you know making a million
bucks or whatever it's gonna be
it's resentment yeah and and and it you
know it goes both ways to it because
then the other person I never held you
back I supported you this entire time
yeah but you know the kind of support
that undercut autonomy and I think
there's a lot of people who I won't say
are comfortable in that but they don't
they don't break out of it because
they're more scared of what you know
what would happen I mean this is what
existential is called anxiety or oxd
anguish it's sometimes translated as
this this realization that it is up to
us
and so you know oftentimes we have to
have the courage to be autonomous and
that may require it feels like breaking
down the relationship you know it might
it might be an e we might have a better
metaphor saying like sort of like you
know when you knock out the rotten walls
from a house that you're gonna remodel
maybe the relationship doesn't have to
go away entirely but it does need
granite countertops you know new floor
yeah
hopefully the foundation is still viable
well that's you know and that's actually
that's a good point you wouldn't really
know until you start ripping away some
of the stuff right yeah hold on sand
smell oh not not just that but like you
peel peel the stuff away from the walls
you don't know whether there's rotten
stuff behind there until you take that
drywall down more plaster or whatever it
is same thing with the floor right you
know you rip up the carpet and rip up
the floorboards now you can see whether
you need to replace beams and you know
joists and stuff like that and so the
idea here would be what is the actual
cause of this anxiety is this something
that is actually arising from this
relationship or is this something that
is to arrive from a previous
relationship
are you living this relationship are you
living the bad outcomes of the last
relationship yeah so yeah so you're
talking about when when people have like
a script set right and they and again
this doesn't have to necessarily be a
romantic relationships this could also
be like employee boss right you had a
bad boss so you go in and you expect
this boss is gonna be a jerk just like
all the other ones have been you know we
we are I'm a landlord so like oh we had
a bad tenant and so I expect the new one
to be potentially bad or and they're not
or they're bad in a completely different
way
that's true people can often surprise us
not by not being bad but by being bad in
totally unexpected manners
it's almost sort of like that thing with
the you know you can't make anything
idiot proof because an idiot will always
find some radically new way to screw
things up maybe we could say that about
relationships yeah that that is that is
a that is a very common issue with just
just like generals fighting the last war
people or you know lawyers litigating
the last case that they had people
living out something that's like they're
the old relationship so you know before
this we were talking about people
cheating on each other and you were
saying that that was particularly
damaging within relationships right
because once you you know MCOs on it's
almost like the whatever foundation
there was gets gets eroded and then if
you head into the new relationship and
you expect oh it's just a matter of time
or you know better keep the that person
away from people that they might be
attracted to or anything like that it
can almost I don't want to say that it
can become a self-fulfilling prophecy
because that assumes that the the
partner who do the cheating somehow was
just you know necessitated that way and
then and I don't want to you know make
that sort of claim because that lets
them off the hook but you know it could
make things very lonely within a
relationship being you know having the
other person always just waiting for you
to screw up you know so I think we
should talk about a little bit as
zero-sum approaches and how this is
potentially a big stumbling block for
making good useful relationships yeah so
you know when we talk about a zero-sum
game we talked about this before yeah
was the last time or the time before
that it's it's from game theory the idea
of a zero-sum game is
a game where any games that I have
result in losses to you
and so when you sum everything up there
you know it results in zero and so this
is in conflict or not conflict in
contrast to a positive sum game where if
we both there's a potential that you
gain and then I also gain so for example
chess is a zero-sum game checkers is a
zero-sum game monopoly is a zero-sum
game Settlers of Catan isn't or is it I
guess only one winner
you can't continue usually a positive
sum game
or usually continuous games so the idea
is to keep on playing and not to
actually have a winner
you know minecraft depending on what
you're doing with it you like you're not
being the kind of person who's what they
call the griever who comes along to
screw things up for other people but you
look at some of the things that that
people create in the Minecraft
environment those are definitely
positive some games you know create
these giant cities and like very you
want to say a single skyscraper out in
the middle of the cornfields of Kansas
yeah there's no point in unless you have
other people and other buildings and
other Commerce around actually be there
I'll tell you who movie villains yes but
that's that's I mean that's not real
life at all so so talking about zero-sum
some games relationships can often wind
up functioning like zero-sum games right
and that's that's one of the dangers in
this and so you know we should we should
talk a little bit about how this
connects up with our theme of autonomy
why does why does people being
autonomous how does that connect up with
with zero-sum games why does that
provoke the kind of reaction
on some people's part to turn things
into zero-sum games I mean we talked
about the anxiety created by other
people's freedom and we talked about I
think you're completely right there's
this worry about like you know past
relationships sometimes intruding into
present relationships is there anything
else going on there with you know people
wanting to be autonomous
go ahead jealousy that you know idea of
wanting to be either like the dominant
person in a relationship to see to keep
the status quo of the relationship going
as much as you can you know there's
always power dynamics and so on
sometimes the idea that someone would
gain certain rights or advantages that
they have feels like they are actually
losing them themselves when in fact they
are not - if you if you are looking at
it as a zero-sum game yeah that's that's
a good point I guess another one would
be like in a work environment wages if
you oh yeah people around you are having
then oh but we do just about the same
thing why are they getting paid so much
more you know or you know they've only
been here for X amount of years how
should they be getting this much money
when I didn't get that for X amount of X
plus five years you know you know I
worked in a place because it was a state
university where everybody's salaries
were public record and boy did that lead
to a lot of issues people would get
quite upset over because you know the
new people getting hired would usually
get hired at a better rate than the
people who'd been there for a while
because you know the wages would would
be increased but only only so much and
you know you can see that like the the
same cohort of people who got hired some
people might have negotiated other
people maybe didn't
they didn't get paid the same and it led
to a lot of resentment and it also it
also led to people who are getting paid
more feeling like well why are you why
are you so bothered by this but going
back to the zero-sum game so it's a
mistake to turn you know it's a mistake
to turn a relationship into a zero-sum
game that's not a good recipe for a
relationship and a lot of people seem to
feel that in order for them to be
autonomous they have to like carve out
things in such a way that the other
person can't encroach on their freedom
and it effectively turns things into a
zero-sum game which then it's not the
same thing as codependency but it seems
like a way to create a failing
relationship doesn't it yeah
so it's an impasse it's a way to not
manage my autonomy well so you know the
Coates back to that idea of like you
know you see the thing that like maybe
be in the common area and someone puts
something up there and now you're like
oh but now I can't put something out
there because they've already put
something up there even though it's
supposed to be a shared space that that
that misunderstood feeling like there's
been a encroachment on my area of
influence so is it possible to be
autonomous oneself in a full sense and
also allow one's partner whatever the
type of relationship it is to be fully
autonomous and for it to be a real
relationship not just sort of a well
I've got my thing over here and you've
got your thing over there and every once
in a while maybe you know sort of like
planets our orbits will coincide for a
little bit and it'll be in the same
place at the same time not the same
place at the same time but at least
aligned I mean is it possible to have a
robust deep relationship in okay
autonomous people what do you think yeah
absolutely
the I think one of the things is you
need to not feel like the things that
your partner does and whatever
relationship you're in on outside of the
relationship are like things that will
encroach upon your own relationship to
that people can have interests that lie
outside of what each other like that
takes that takes a feeling of security
to be able to go along with that right
right yeah and so I guess that would
come down to what makes good
relationships and you know communication
is definitely one of those things and to
be a very open and honest and you know
to be very upfront about what you need
and the information that you need from
that person and as long as you have good
channels of communication and you are
telling your partner that and you will
have a much better way of resulting you
know having that that strong
relationship even though there might be
some autonomy within the actions there
yeah you know when we're communicating
with each other
you know a lot when we when we argue
when we fight it's through communicating
and we can communicate in verbal and
nonverbal ways you know giving somebody
the silent treatment as a communication
with them it's a hey you're a jerk and I
don't want to talk to you and I'm gonna
you know keep doing this for however
long one of the aspects of communication
that that ties in with autonomy that I
think is quite difficult in
relationships is you know communicating
is never just a matter of straight-out
information it always involves values it
always involves how we feel about things
and what we think about them and
judgments that we're making so you know
if I'm willing to let's say we're
talking about a friendship like like you
and me
if I'm willing to allow you to express
the values that matter to you within the
way that we communicate I'm allowing you
to be more autonomous or to express your
autonomy in creating space for your
autonomy right in a way that can then
feel I don't know respectful for you or
supportive or valued whereas if I'm
trying to make you communicate in the
same way that I do that's probably going
to be a failure and it's a lack of
respect for your autonomy and you'd
probably feel it is an imposition if I'm
like I you know I talk this way and I
say these sort of things you need to do
that exact sort of thing too or else we
can't be friends you know I think you
you would you would view that you know
quite rightly so as an attempt to
control you and control isn't really
compatible with autonomy I would go
continue in that same vein to the idea
of you know being afraid to say
something because it might upset your
partner even though it's a very
important thing for you and you feel a
need to restrain because your partner is
so I know I guess fragile non resilient
yeah I able that lie off the handle yeah
yeah and and it's it's bad for both of
you like if you if you're the one that
is fragile one then how can you have
open how can you have a partner that
feels like they can be open and honest
with you and the other one feels like
their autonomy is being restricted yeah
and that feels bad
there we have a sort of negative a
negative reaction to it I mean I
remember reading Cicero talks about this
he says that it's natural to human
beings to want to not just feel free but
actually be able to do things like a
free person you know and he's writing
this in a slave Society
quite interestingly so he's kind of
recognizing that a lot of the population
is probably you know pretty ticked off
at any given point in time but I think
in relationships there there's there's
quite a few cases where where you know
people trample over each other's
autonomy and then you know when somebody
starts to get upset about it it turns
into a fight but often times they don't
get to what the real core core issue is
which is that we we have to be willing
to show each other a certain kind of
respect and respect for another person's
autonomy doesn't mean just showing
respect in the way that we would like it
it means you know showing respect in the
ways that they can recognize and and we
would like as well so like if you were
to tell me I don't like when you say
this word and I'm like well that's a
totally arbitrary imposition then you
know who are you to tell me how I can
talk the problems with mean not with you
I mean I may there may be some weird
psychological reason why you don't like
a certain word like I can't say you know
Tweedledum you know because you've got a
traumatic experience that I don't know
Disneyland or something like that
terrible flashbacks but if I can't if I
can't respect recognize and respect that
there's a problem there and the problem
is more on my side than on yours right
it's a silly example I yeah I guess I
missed the whose side is sue here well
your I would be the one who would not be
respecting your autonomy in determining
what what counts is respect for you okay
yes so you know coming to freedom this
kind of reminds me of you know how in
our technological age we have new tools
that allow us to communicate but they
also are new tools that we can use to
restrict the freedoms of the people that
were in relationships with and so I see
this you know you know if we have cell
phones in our pockets and we are
obsessively able to be contacted at any
point in time then we have the ability
to if one person in
a relationship is overly controlling to
be able to get in contact with them and
expect them to respond at any point in
time and you're seeing this actually a
lot with our our lockdown it having so
many people work from home there's been
a massive uptick in monitoring software
for people working yeah yeah the
software takes a photo of you with the
camera takes a photo of whatever you're
working on makes a point to like give a
report about what things that you're
looking at both in your browser like how
many times you're you're working on your
like documents or your spreadsheets as
well as like it will only count time
work on something if you are typing keys
or moving your mouse on and will like
present whole reports which I seem is
like I wish that's people that were
doing this we just saying okay what is
the thing that you actually want in this
work relationship
it's the output right it's not like you
want someone to be staring at a single
document for eight hours a day
especially I mean anything creatively
worked there are certain things that are
like you know you have to figure out the
good metric and certain metrics will
require you to be like if you're doing
sales or something you have to be an
what but if you're and you're doing
tickets for tech support or something
and it's the number of tickets that you
get through as long as that hits a
certain metric then what does it matter
I think though that for some people the
metrics aren't what they're really after
they they do want to dominate the other
person or control the other person for
whatever reason you know yeah
there's an interest in my things the oh
right
yeah yeah it's not just that it's not
right it is it is you know ethically
wrong but it's also damaging to oneself
and to the other person and to the
relationship that it creates all sorts
of resentments there's a there's a big
controversy right now it's an end of
this
master and you know where we did the
pivot to online for education and there
are quite a few people professors who
are like trying to make tests as
difficult for their students as possible
and trip them up and you know wondering
how they can keep the students from
possibly cheating and there's a lot of
you know thought and and not ink so much
but you know pixels being devoted to
this and you know my attitude is wow you
must really distrust your students if
that's what your focus is and if you're
trying to make like problem one of the
things was making making tests that they
can't possibly solve you know use why
the hell would you do that to like rub
their nose and you know how you know how
little they know or something like that
the point of education is impaired
students down it's to you know build
them up but I think a lot of professors
have have lost sight of that
and I think there's a lot of bosses who
probably have lost sight of that as well
we should remember a time where I took a
a three-hour coding exam that was remote
and so they required me to install
monitoring software on my computer and
they would not allow me to use the
restroom once the exam started and so
about two and a half hours in I really
needed to use the restroom and like
there's a proctor it's like can I leave
to use the restroom like no and I'm like
well why would I ever want to work for
you if this is the way that you're gonna
try when I go into you know this type of
thing it was a very bad experience my
part should hit that question really
quick yeah but that's that's actually a
really good point you could say this is
also very quickly about like job
interviews if you go to a job interview
and they treat you like like garbage why
would you ever want to work there
because that's the one time they have to
like show you sort of like the date you
know if somebody is terrible on a date
why would you want to be in a
relationship with this right but yeah
let's let's go to the question which
kind of ties in with the cell phone
thing right yeah so there
from reddit with from rudder on
Intimidator
says so it seems like she can't go half
a day without calling me or texting me
to help her with something I always go
and help because I'm a nice guy and I
love her a lot but she especially likes
to do it when I'm actually busy and need
to get things done she expects me to
take time out of my day and believe me
believe it or not my time is actually
very valuable to go watch her dogs for a
couple of hours while she goes into
something fun and he's asking like is
this right or wrong what do you think
Greg I think that that's a pretty
screwed up relationship most likely and
I mean it's interesting that in just
asking this this is clearly I would say
somebody who is in a quandary about this
they're wondering whether this is normal
or this is abnormal even being kind of
in in the dark about that I'd say is a
problem sign wouldn't you yeah the it's
I assumed that this is a really
relationship and we're always rather
blind and you know thinking like wow
like it's so great and you you get yeah
yeah you know love is blind especially
in the first you know six months and and
he's just finally realizing like coming
up for air and it's like oh this doesn't
seem like I'm in a relationship where my
partner respects my time and I guess my
autonomy to a certain extent well I
think this is an interference with
autonomy if if you're trying to get
something done and do something yourself
and then you have somebody calling you
and expecting that you should like drop
what you're doing and join in on
whatever it is that they want done
that's not allowing you to decide what
to do with your time what to do with
your day
I mean there's probably a lot dogs are
nice but there's probably a lot more
valuable things to do than watching dogs
there's not even like going in and
spending quality time with your partner
it's can you do this thing so I can do
something else yeah that I think that's
a real red flag and so you know one of
the things that we were talking about a
little bit earlier is communication and
this sounds like a relationship where
some communication is happening she's
you know texting camera phoning him and
saying I need you to do X Y Z and he's
saying okay I guess I'll do I'll change
my day and do that but there he's not
definitely not communicating with her
about how this makes him feel or whether
it shows that he's being devalued and
what he would like in the relationship
so it seems a real problem to me so I
think we should move on to our practice
here which ties in with this I think
quite yeah well all right what do you
please tell us about it so you know I
think we can just call this a
communication practice you know some of
the practices that we've looked at are
more action oriented or mindfulness
oriented you know where you're thinking
about something this has to do with how
you're approaching somebody else and the
you know the thing that that it's it's
absolutely centered on is doing
something namely telling your partner
what it is that you want and I think a
lot of people wait until they've crossed
a certain line and they're like that's
it I've had it now I'm gonna tell you
exactly what I want that's not the way
to do it the way to do it is to
deliberately tell your partner at a good
time hey this is this is what I need
from you this is what I want from you
this is what makes me feel supported or
loved or respected or whatever whatever
it is in the modality of the
relationship and so there's there's a
couple you could say components to this
one is thinking to yourself before you
actually get there well what is it that
you want
to convey to them what is it that you
actually do want sometimes when we think
about things it turns out that there's a
difference between needs and desires and
wants and wins some of the things that
we say we're we absolutely have to have
are kind of you know either negotiable
or turn out not to be that important so
clarifying for ourself is very important
and then you know you don't want to make
it dramatic there's a tendency I think
and a temptation for a lot of people to
invest communication with a lot more
drama than it needs it it's it's
perfectly fine to say to the other
person listen I you know in the case of
this guy he could say listen my time is
valuable I would like to spend it on
things that I want to do or with you I
don't want to for example watch your
dogs will you go off to do you know
whatever it is that you're doing and you
can say that to a person in a calm way
without you know bringing in all sorts
of other extraneous matters all right
but that requires a little bit of
practice I think so this reminds me a
lot of some really good advice that I
heard from Dan Savage and it's a
reframing device and it's good when you
two are fighting you both need to
remember that it's you two versus the
problem not you versus him if it's you
versus him then they both lose yeah
that's that's actually a great way to
frame it and it's and the problem isn't
just a wedge to use against the other
person - it's it's something that you
want to try to resolve so I guess you
know another thing that would fit in
with this is reminding oneself about the
value of the relationship itself that
you know ultimately you want things to
be better I mean this is what this is
where you can tell whether you're
codependent or not if you're codependent
you actually don't want the relationship
to be better you want it to
- you know stay the same this is where
you can tell whether you're kind of
sadistic or not or cruel right if maybe
you really do want just to beat the
other person up well you know then it's
up to them whether they want to stick
around for that and then you might you
know if you realize that you might want
to take a look at yours so we should we
should wrap up yeah so I think just you
don't expect your partner to read your
mind as well to add to that practice now
but how's it well do you want to have
any last thoughts or yeah I guess it was
tendon closed this week out with a quote
from Daniel H pink control leads to
compliance autonomy leads to engagement
[Music]
[Music]
you